welcome to another Dr Sadler's honest
reviews this is a series in which I give
as the title suggests rather unvarnished
and sometimes critical and
straightforward honest reviews of mostly
recent Works in Practical philosophy
understood in a very broad sense and the
book that we have this time is pretty
new
2022 and it's by the author carniades
this of course is a pseudonym there's
nobody out there actually named
karniades as far as I know since ancient
times carniadis was a very famous
skeptic within Plato's Academy and the
book is called our all lives equal why
cost benefit analysis values Rich lives
more and how philosophy can fix it so
this fits very very much within the
Wheelhouse of practical philosophy it's
uh you know a place where philosophy
policy and economics are coinciding and
I will say
um before we jump into all of the meat
of the review that I think this is a
pretty good book
um it may be a little dry for some
readers as we'll talk about when we get
to the problematic stuff at the very end
but it is a really solid volume so I
look forward to telling you all about
this work
we always begin by talking about the
three s's style structure and summary
and so let me start with the summary
this time there is a proposition you
could say that is running throughout the
entire work and you know it's it's
connected to the subtitle why cost
benefit analysis values Rich lives more
and how philosophy can fix it and there
is a philosophy fix it being offered in
this work after examining how cost
benefit analysis is supposed to work and
some of the guiding assumptions behind
it and who uses it and how they use it
and the author cardiotics is going to be
arguing a case that ultimately if we
want to have a more Equitable Fair
ethical distribution of benefits and
harms which is what cost benefit
analysis says can be a tool for helping
us with then we need to shift away
from assessing
all these matters because they have to
be quantitatively workable in terms we
have to move away from absolute
willingness to pay or all sorts of other
assumptions and start thinking in terms
of percentage willingness to pay so what
we would do with that is to begin
valuing different people's lives
depending on their their you know social
status or income or wealth we would
begin evaluating them on kind of a More
Level Playing Field and that is really
the central contention that is made
throughout the entire work so that
that's a a summary of sorts and I guess
to add to the summary you could say that
this is a a book of philosophy applied
philosophy aiming at making that case by
going through things systematically
methodically trying to close any any
possible loopholes and address any
concerns the reasonable concerns that
might be brought up by various types of
readers and it's it's essentially a
policy argument and an Ethics argument
so that's the
that's the summary as far as style goes
you know it's a very readable work it's
difficult to write popular philosophy
without watering things down too much
and this book is actually succeeding in
maintaining a lot of philosophical rigor
but also you know writing in a way that
is doing some justice to the material
but also presenting it for ordinary
people who might be interested in it and
specialists in other fields now as far
as the structure goes it's divided into
three main sections after the beginning
let them eat toxic waste which is
beginning by talking about Larry Summers
and this argument that he was making
about how we should essentially
distribute toxic waste to the third war
world because their lives aren't as
valuable this is a Lawrence Summers Memo
from 1991 it then goes into three main
sections uh titled how we got here that
that's a short one it's got two chapters
in it and that's looking at some of the
bases about cost-benefit analysis and
there's actually a chapter called how to
value a life
then uh the the second section
insufficient responses talking about
um why the the
predominant ways of understanding these
matters and therefore engaging in policy
arguments are not
really capturing what what needs to be
captured and there's five chapters there
and then the third part is is much
longer percentage willingness to pay
it's making the case for this in a
number of different ways and that third
section actually includes two chapters
that are essentially extended case
studies uh chapter 14 the value of black
lives talking about risks involved with
policing and the broken windows approach
to to communities and policing and
allocation of resources uh the various
dangers that are associated with it and
then very interestingly and it shows you
how contemporary work this is chapter 15
is called covid-19 your money or your
life and I mean that's a very important
topic to be considering in our our world
this is probably there's a bit of a
digression not the only pandemic that
we'll see in our lifetimes unless of
course you know we get killed by one of
them uh so you know it's uh it's really
well thought through I would say another
interesting feature of it
there is a list of thought experiments
with
um you know index to the chapters one of
the features of this work is that there
are a number of what are being Builders
thought experiments we'll talk about
whether they are truly thought
experiments or not a little bit later
but there's certainly good cases good
ways of illustrating what's going on in
there and there's several uh appendices
that are also quite useful
um one of the appendices has to do with
carniadis well actually uh you know one
of them does and then there's there's an
aw about the author at the end so
appendix C is a note on skepticism
carnitis is you know invoking a
skeptical position how is this uh rather
you know we could say dogmatic
assertions about life and policy and
things like that how is that compatible
with skepticism and cardiologist makes a
a good case for that and then a lot of
the other things are about how lives
indeed are actually valued and it's
providing us with the information that
we need to figure this this stuff out
and to be well informed about it there's
also an Extended references section
which is very nice
um it's a number of pages and so if
somebody wants to follow up and do more
work on this they can do so
uh and then there's an about the author
so I I should actually mention this here
because I'm sure some people are kind of
curious they've heard me mention that
this is a pseudonym so carniades if you
don't know is somebody like me uh the
Creator producer of a lot of YouTube
videos and and carniotics has been
around I think about as long as my
channel has and is you know roughly On a
par although uh carniadis is doing
different kinds of videos than I'm doing
but they're you know they're covering a
lot of similar ground and they're very
you know well thought out and
educational so it says cardiadis is the
creator of the educational philosophy
YouTube channel
carniades.org as well as an
International Development practitioner
with experience bringing philosophical
analysis to bear on the Myriad problems
in global development and I like this
line the channel was founded with a goal
of repaving the Agora with the rubble of
the Ivory Tower making philosophy and
Phil philosophical debate more
accessible for a broader audience and
championing philosophical skepticism so
you know very on point with with that so
that's probably enough about the
structure style and summary at this
point
so what are the key or Central ideas of
this work as mentioned earlier the the
central thesis of this work is that if
we if we want to Value lives more or
less equally without privileging or
prioritizing Rich lives within
particular communities or globally
prioritizing rich people in developed
countries over everybody else in the
world then we need to think very
carefully about how we do cost benefit
analysis and you know really good point
that gets made in the work well why not
just get away from cost benefit analysis
you know we've got other ways of doing
ethics and I do want to mention
something here I teach business ethics
and one of the articles that I make sure
to incorporate when we're go going
through the field is by Robert Audi an
incredibly important ethicist of the
20th and 21st century and he actually
has a great article that makes the case
why cost benefit analysis isn't just for
utilitarians or other consequentialists
but even virtue ethicists and
deontologists including conscient
deontologists we really you know
shouldn't be careless in how we apply
cost benefit analysis but we also should
use it and that's one of the cases that
carniotics is making in here that we're
stuck with this tool the economists and
other people who get to advise people on
policy the policy makers are using this
as a tool so what we want to do
is find ways to improve the tool improve
the uses of the tool and so you know as
mentioned one of the central ways of
doing that is to get away from what we
call absolute willingness to pay which
is you know you ask somebody well if if
you were going to lower the risk to you
know yourself by one in a thousand uh
you know toxic waste dump is going to be
built into your community how much would
you pay to not have that risk or how
much would you pay for a benefit now
obviously uh if you're rich and you
don't have as many constraints you've
got a much greater not just willingness
but capacity to pay
and there's all sorts of other
ramifications of this many poor people
simply don't have the resources to do
that so what we should do according to
cardiotics and I think this is a very
good case is move away from absolute
willingness to pay and move to
percentage willingness to pay how much
of your income or resources what
percentage are you willing to give up in
order to lower your risk or in order to
gain some sort of benefit and as he
points out when we look at things across
the world
it turns out that
things are fairly uniform among people
so if we do that we're going to have a
much more fair just Equitable however
you want to frame it a morally
acceptable way of figuring these matters
out ranging from you know where to
locate pollution to
providing medical benefits to whether we
should inoculate people how much should
vaccines cost if anything all sorts of
issues can be handled in this way and
there is actually a really Central
problematic running here how to
determine matters in in ways that are
actually mapping onto our basic
assumption that I think most people
share I mean there are some people who
clearly don't share this for various
reasons that you know
when we're making decisions that affect
a lot of people we should be fair we
should be ethical in in doing so
um
chapter 13 I think is particularly uh
interesting in this respect it's
actually
titled the lie at the heart of economics
and carniades is beginning by looking at
some of the really key assumptions that
are that are being made
um so here's here's a little bit of uh
what the text says the concerns we have
explored here represent more than a
minor issue relegated to the valuation
of Life the concern about absolute
willingness to pay represents something
much deeper it is a failing at the heart
of Economics as a discipline to
accurately measure welfare this failing
systematically prioritizes the needs of
the wealthy over the needs of the poor
it is baked into the basic assumptions
of Economics that the needs of those who
can pay more are worth more economics is
not merely the Dismal science it is the
immoral science because it was it uses
mathematics to hide a deeply biased and
political assumption resting at its
foundation that poor people don't matter
only rich people do and so
carnitis wants to as a good philosopher
to uncover these assumptions to question
them to bring them into the sunlight and
say this is not okay he also points out
when it comes to philosophers unlike
many philosophers who would throw the
economics Department out with the bath
water I think it can be reformed
although it may take some effort and one
of the you know points that he's making
is that we cannot just uh say as
philosophers or as people who would you
know more broadly speaking want to
prioritize ethics we can't just say ah
get rid of cost benefit analysis ah you
know just just you know wing it or go by
your gut because we we do need
techniques for figuring these matters
out there's a good reason why
cross-benefit analyzes and all the
assumptions that go along with them
became one of the predominant ways of
determining how resources and harms
benefits and you know risks are in fact
going to be distributed so if we if we
get rid of the tool altogether that's
not any good either as cardiotics points
out as a matter of fact that's you know
there's a good case that that'll be even
more arbitrary and less ethical in doing
that so I think that's a you know a
pretty good way to summarize some of the
the key ideas in the work as you're
going to find it
um and maybe we'll we'll leave off there
there's a lot more that could be said
about what you're going to find in this
work but
I'll just mention that what what is
being constructed here is a complex
argument that has a lot of moving Parts
uh entails some what seem to be
digressions but everything is actually
connected together within the work and
that's you know really one of the good
points so we should move on next to the
other things that I find valuable or
good about this work
so what are the good points about this I
mean to begin with I think that this is
very well thought through structured and
researched uh again you know I'll Point
towards the
um sources that you know or the
references that is
oh about 15 pages roughly uh in the back
you know so you can follow up your own
work I also think that
um the summaries that hernia carniadis
is providing of these sources is really
quite good too it's you know it there's
a lot of doing what a good philosopher
does which is to say so here's what the
source is saying here's what I like
about it here's what I find problematic
why do I find it problematic making all
of those critical distinctions that's
very important
um
I think you know the book successfully
makes its case uh so it it provides an
argument and it's a Well worked out
argument that you know
ought to motivate us to to want to do
things differently it's making the case
that Quest benefit analyzes are in fact
needed but they need to be improved and
the way that they're going to be
improved ultimately is by having
philosophers and not just any
philosophers because a lot of
philosophers would probably do a bad job
with this
bringing philosophers into the
discussion I think it makes a great case
for bringing applied philosophy into
greater communication with policy making
and with economics on that point
another thing that I do like about the
book that comes out at several different
points is when we're engaging in
thinking about people's preferences and
willingness to pay as you know something
that we can measure
carniadis mentions that institutions and
governments strictly speaking don't
actually have preferences as such
although they play a massive role not
just in making policy themselves right
but also in communicating with each
other about the policies that are going
to be made or advocated or or worked out
or you know whatever we're going to say
so that's that's a really critical point
uh to bring up and to think through
I think that another really
solid feature of the book is that you
know if you read this it's ranging over
a number of different
theories issues approaches assumptions
in economics in policy making in ethics
and moral philosophy
and doing a great job in not losing the
thread of the argument so anything that
appears to be just a digression actually
figures in here that's in here in a way
that's uh in some respects quite
admirable
you know
it's it's tough to write
extended arguments well and carnitis
clearly has some talent for that
um
it's also good on you know hitting on
the um problems with philosophers in
particular you know
why it is that so like he says
um as ideological purists philosophers
have an inclination to propose solutions
that may have negative practical
implications but are justified in theory
politicians on the other hand have a pro
proclivity for solutions that are
practically and politically viable even
when those Solutions are not justified
by the underlying theories so figuring
out how to connect these two together
that is really the the difficult stuff
right and if the politicians themselves
are not going to do it and the
likelihood is that they're not then
philosophers need to be advocating for
this or people who understand philosophy
need to be advocating for this in ways
that are very pragmatic another thing
that I think is particularly
interesting about this work and I would
say is a good point although in some
respects it can also work against the
book is the Myriad of as the authors
calling them thought experiments which
are mostly about you know this this
group over here prefers this to this
degree and they have this amount of uh
resources or income they're all fairly
quantitative
if we want to call them thought
experiments I would actually just call
them case studies or examples and I
think considered as case studies or
examples they do a lot of good work
in moving the general argument forward
and giving people ways of wrapping their
heads around what's what's going on I
mean you could you could chart them out
on paper if you wanted to and I think
that could be quite helpful so
you know the other thing that I'll say
too is I think that
um
carniades has done a really good job in
the writing of of this
and it's
I would say is clear and as
interesting as this kind of material
ought to be oh I'll point one other
thing out too there are a number of kind
of cool illustrations that you find
throughout the work and I myself like
those some people might not like that
sort of thing in what's essentially like
a policy argument book but I think these
are are pretty cool so that those are
the things that I really like about the
work
foreign
is there anything that's problematic
about the work I mean problematic is a
better word than bad because I don't
have any criticisms as such about the
work but I do think that there are some
things that might put certain readers
off I mean to begin with if you are the
kind of person who's like oh I just
don't understand math whatsoever I mean
I would say in that case you're probably
lying to yourself and you should like
start you know learning math what you
can do as an adult but there's some
people that are put off by quantitative
analysis and this book is full of
quantitative analysis in part because
that's that's the topic you're not going
to get away from that it is about cost
benefit uh you know approaches to things
which rely on quantification so there's
a lot of numbers in the work and some
readers might not get into that and they
I think there's a lot of readers who
might also find this a bit on the dry
side and that's unfortunate because I
kind of gather that as I said I think
the author made this as interesting as
the material can be made
while still writing for a a general
audience not just a bunch of policy
wonks or you know philosophers
but there's only so much you can do with
that so is that problematic maybe it
depends on the kind of reader there's
nothing actually wrong with the book
it's just it's not going to peel
necessarily to everybody
I also think you know calling the
examples thought experiments is a little
bit
ambitious you know it's it's like
um calling and you know 18 to 23 foot
boat a ship when it's not really such
but that's kind of a quibble on my part
so I don't I don't think that's really a
big deal or something that should keep
somebody from reading the work and uh
frankly that that's all that I have by
way of mild criticism
for the book
um
I on the whole I think it's quite good
so final thoughts about this work I
think having read through it that this
is actually a really good book and
I wish
that we had a population and readership
here in the United States that would
like eat this sort of stuff up because
it's I think it's making a really
important case and it's uh it's quite
needed and probably not just of course
in the U.S but throughout the the world
um
so
I recommend it I then again you know if
you really really don't like
quantitative analysis you might find it
a bit off-putting and dry but I think
that you know from an ethical
perspective this is actually making a
really significant contribution and I'd
also say and I'm going to say this by
way of closing
this is doing public philosophy really
well in in a particular mode of doing
public philosophy when it comes to the
intersection between policy makers
including politicians and you know
important institutions and economists
and philosophers this is really setting
down a bunch of important challenges
right at the heart of that so I I think
it's a quite a good book